all right i'm laura ingram this is a
special midnight edition of the ingram
angle from washington tonight
and after watching kamala harris
i thought to myself no wonder joe biden
headed to gettysburg on monday he was
babbling on there about
oh the need for national unity and
bipartisanship we had kind of the nice
guy of unclear approach
that was all an effort to convince you
that democrats still
believe in america's history and our
traditions
but what you saw tonight from a haughty
indignant kamala harris was what the
biden campaign has been trying to hide
that the democrats are now the party of
radicals
by radicals and four radicals
kamala harris struggled to lie away
biden's real agenda on lockdowns
and his true plans to for instance
abolish the fossil fuel industry
you know there's a very good chance that
if biden wins the woman you saw tonight
will become president of the united
states yet
she refused to answer multiple easy
basic questions how would you describe
our fundamental relationship with china
are we competitors
adversaries enemies susan the
trump administration's
perspective and approach to china has
resulted in the loss of american
lives american jobs
and america's standing if roe v wade is
overturned
what would you want california to do no
restrictions on access to abortion
first of all joe biden and i are both
people of faith
and it's insulting to suggest that we
would
knock anyone for their faith susan are
voting right now they'd like to know if
you and joe biden are going to
pack the supreme court if you don't get
your way in this nomination
of the 50 people who
president trump appointed to the court
of appeals for lifetime appointments
not one is black this is what
they've been doing you want to talk
about packing a court
no no the question was about packing the
court maybe she should have just asked
if she could have bought a vowel or
something
well but true true to you know to be
honest here you know
pence punted on some questions too but
at least the trump record
is there for everybody to see economic
prosperity peace deals in the middle
east holding china accountable
recovery even after the pandemic hit
but the biden campaign knows much of
what it has planned
isn't popular and they know they can't
deliver higher wages for most americans
so what they do and you saw her to do
this tonight is obfuscate
and prevaricate now when someone is
as left-wing as harris is you have to
ask
is she ever going to use her power for
the good of the middle class
how about the working class small
business owners
americans of faith the answer
never biden will not only make your life
miserable with lockdowns next year a
point that unfortunately mike pence did
not make tonight
but they'll also make you miserable by
leaving you
poorer less free and less safe
kamala harris true to her liberal san
francisco political roots
hates much about this country after all
she believes
like biden now that we're a systemically
racist nation that is a poisonous
awful terrible lie that mike pence
called out
this presumption that you hear
consistently
from joe biden and kamala harris that
that america is systemically racist and
that as joe biden said that he believes
that
law enforcement has an implicit bias
against minorities is
is a great insult to the men and women
who serve in law enforcement
it is remarkable that that when senator
tim scott tried to pass a police reform
bill
brought together a group of republicans
and democrats senator harris
you got up and walked out of the room we
don't have to choose between supporting
law enforcement
improving public safety and supporting
our african-american
neighbors all of our minorities by the
way she was smirking through most of
that answer
kamala harris threw down the race card
tonight and she lied
about what president trump said about
charlottesville of course susan page
didn't correct the record
and she did this all because she and joe
biden can't refute and certainly can't
beat the trump pence record on helping
african americans
joe biden though i think to a lot of
folks a lot of you who are watching
you're still up in the midwest and the
east coast maybe to you he represents
the democrat party of the past like a
safer
democrat party of 30 years ago it was a
little bit more moderate maybe for a lot
of you
you think about biden and you have kind
of a nostalgic
viewpoint but his talk of scranton
and his blue collar appeal it's all bunk
most of those folks
those blue-collar folks they're now for
trump and for good reason
the democrats are a party of wealthy
donors
and radical ivory tower types who want
to impose their extreme
anti-american agenda on the rest of us
that's who they are today
so all of the pain and suffering that
the liberal governors and mayors coveted
restrictions and lockdowns
have caused you that's not going to
bother democrats of today
whether on masks or travel limits the
rules
never apply to them or their
well-connected friends
they see kovid remember as a political
gift
which their old pal jane fonda admitted
today
i just think um covet is god's gift to
the left
it's really really funny well she did
speak the truth
when the other cable networks put the
chart up on the screen day in and day
out of covid deaths and
and infections they're not doing it
to empathize and inform you they're
doing it for one reason and one reason
only
as a political weapon against president
trump
kamala and pretty much everyone who
could end up in biden's cabinet
will be closer ideologically to
alexandria ocasio-cortez
than william jefferson clinton it's a
different party
now listen to how she spoke to the
parents of an american hostage who was
brutally murdered by
isis the inauthenticity
was palpable to the mueller family i i
know
about your daughter's case and i'm so
sorry
i'm so sorry what happened to her
is awful and it should have never
happened
get ready to hear that a lot if biden
wins
oh it's awful i'm so sorry that your job
was shipped to china
oh it's awful i'm so sorry that your
kids can't go to in-person classes
because we're locked down
or i'm sorry it's so awful that your
neighborhoods
aren't safe but we're not going to try
to offend anyone by enforcing the laws
i'm sorry you feel bad that mount
rushmore
has been demolished you're going to hear
that a lot
if biden harris wins the policies they
will enact
will be favorable to pro-china the
pro-china caucus on wall street
and in big business their policies will
be favorable to the global
scientific establishment pushing
lockdowns and climate change rules
they'll be supportive of leftist ideas
that come out of academia
and they'll be hostile to the middle
class and hostile to american history
and traditions
they'll be hostile to the oil and gas
industry hostile to practicing catholics
traditional christians and orthodox jews
this was another debate where the
moderator
was clearly in the tank for the
democrats most questions were worded
against trump
susan page interrupted pence for time
frequently and let harris drone on and
on when she got indignant
so pence did fine tonight he obviously
won and harris did
nothing to contradict what we already
know about her
none of her eye rolling or grimacing
or the insect moving on pence's head is
going to change
this simple fact the markets were up 500
points today
because trump's recovering and getting
stronger he's willing to do a targeted
stimulus
i do wish that pence said that the biden
obama economy in 2016 was so strong
so vibrant so great for the working
class
that americans decided to turn over the
country to donald trump
a guy with zero government experience